good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy monday
hope everybody everyone to break the bad
news usually it's a happy
thursday
friday no today's monday but you know
what
tuesday instead of
looking at this in a negative light okay
let's look at it in a positive light
we're coming up show us how show us the
way we're coming up on a long weekend we
are so it's not an ordinary week this
week does have tinges of specialness and
starting next week this is our last week
of really
winter spring
because then next week like you can wear
white pants joggers
rolling into summer yeah so enjoy the
space that we're in make the most of
this last
week of spring and you know what monday
is a curse i
agree it's also an opportunity
and i don't think we should forget that
rise and grind ah
and figure your [ __ ] out
okay that's your motivational moment
from claudia yeah you don't get you
don't get a lot of them you get them
one seventh of the time i'm a deeply
negative person you are yeah oh i'm
sorry i thought you said you don't get a
lot of mondays and i'm like you get them
as much as you get i you'll get a lot of
motivational moments no you don't but
i'm so glad that you're here on a
positive note today i mean if there's
ever time for us to be positive on the
show it is today because like this
weekend gave us everything we as pop
culture enthusiast kardashian stans
could ever want yeah
uh
it was our cup run is over honestly it
was so good it was overwhelming it was
really like a royal wedding of sorts
especially because it was like far in so
it felt like you know the time was
different
twelve o'clock why are they getting
ready for the wedding okay
the biggest wedding weekend recap since
probably megan and harry and even still
like this was so much more there were so
many more events so many more like
characters to keep track of and it was
relatively public
yeah mostly because the wedding itself
was on the edge of a cliff so like if
you were standing nearby with a camera
and you were a paparazzi like we had
full
like high quality photos of everyone
arriving and alabama was like all over
social north was on tick tock so there
was like a lot of content coming out of
this event where i thought maybe it
would have been more private but it
wasn't because honestly they couldn't
control the kids
right but also i feel like courtney and
travis don't care they're like we're
going to be ourselves whether there's
cameras or no cameras if you want to
film us go ahead if you don't don't yeah
it was pretty cool actually like the
level of like how much they didn't care
like kylie was tick-tocking there was
actually so much content coming out of
the wedding so much content our cup run
is over i didn't turn my tv on once this
weekend i watched the kardashian wedding
weekend yeah and i didn't realize how
much as a society we needed that no same
i also did watch i didn't watch a lot of
tv either because i was consuming
content on my phone but i did watch high
school musical 3. so good and i think as
a society again we needed that we do
need that we always need high school
musical one you could skip two and three
you could skip two for sure um and all i
have to say is i want the rest of my
life to feel just like a high school
musical
[Music]
yes speaking of gorgeousness i'm really
missing bryce and straight i know doing
the show without them like it really
isn't worth it's like not it's not an
existence worth pursuing but i do have
to say like friday was was a little
chaotic and i do feel so distracted by
them when i'm here so while i do miss
them i am ready to get back to the task
at hand especially today we have
unburdened ourselves it's monday we
haven't done that in a while we have the
kravis wedding we also just have like
general news for throughout the weekend
so the fact that they're not here like
is devastating literally why are we here
but don't forget we have pillow bryson's
trice which is just as good they'll
carry us through i know not every day
can be brass and straws from raz and
strasbourg brazilians jazz and
brazilians jasmine brazen strides and
rises rats and breasts i was trying to
think over the weekend what tune is that
i was trying to think too like did we
make that up or is that like a jingle
like
like okay when we do snitch on the toes
that's we've got the funk but um thank
you
what jam is this
[Music]
there's no way we made it it might be
something like for just
no
have you guys ever heard that tune
it's a common jingle it has to be have
you ever heard it yeah is it like a nerd
no is it like a nursery rhyme what is it
someone will know or it's just something
in our heads rather than well that's
true it is something in our heads so
miss them dearly but like we've got a
job to do and
end i'd be remiss
i would be devastated i would even yeah
yeah i would i would be heartbroken if i
didn't let you guys know that right
after today's show we are recording an
interview
with probably the most
prestigious guest we've ever had on the
show probably someone who like we're
most excited to have come through those
doors yeah it's gonna be um it's gonna
be huge i don't wanna spoil it but it'll
be on tomorrow's episode maybe if we're
like feeling crazy maybe we'll drop it
on youtube first i'm i'm enjoying doing
that me too also subscribe don't forget
youtube.com make a gmail please that's
gonna be sickening also i just want to
update everyone on a little life update
from moi yeah uh i got an aura ring oh i
thought you were going to talk about oh
my breastfeeding journey i'm just like
not in the mood guys
i'm at a low right yeah it happens you
know i was so high yeah oh after the lip
tie procedure oh harold was eating so
good i was like breastfeeding i could do
this forever
last night i was like i'm done
no i'm not done but i'm experiencing a
low so just that's fine i thought that's
what you're going to say but what were
you going to say i got an ora ring and
i'm really excited about it what's like
your sleep grade so
two nights ago i got which is great i
was not gonna get one because i was like
my sleep is trash and
why would i get one now but two nights
ago i actually got good sleep because i
went to sleep right when harold did at
like eight o'clock uh so my sleep was
like at a 97 because i
did a lot of long like i just long
stretches yeah and then last night was
like in the 80s but
i like it because it's a wearable so
it's also tracking my steps like my
apple watch it might i'm sorry i don't
have an apple
my health app yesterday like says i
walked a thousand steps because like i
went on the treadmill and i like you
know was doing all these things around
my house that like it doesn't count
treadmill steps unless i was holding my
phone the whole time no right i was like
doing chores and stuff but my ordering i
had 10 000 steps yesterday i got it so
i'm glad that it's gonna be tracking my
steps my sleep and just help and now
it's like gamified for me so
now i want to get more steps so i'm
gonna work out more you have to sleep
with it of course right to get the sleep
tracking like yeah i can't sleep in
jewelry claudia i don't wear any jeweler
i don't wear rings
it's so comfortable really yeah yeah
it's fine to wear that would be like the
hardest part for me no it's really
such a cool little gadget and i'm
looking forward to you know bettering
myself with it bettering yourself is i
mean i've never done it but i hear it's
amazing it can feel great yeah i'm
mostly interested in it just like
tracking my activity
that'll keep me accountable you know
because now it's like i want to have a
better day than yesterday which means i
have to get my [ __ ] ass up and get to
the gym do you have a um a name for your
aura ring jackie aurora oh that's good i
was gonna suggest if it's keeping you
accountable teddy mellencamp oh also
again maybe like if you got one you
could call it that if i put one on it
would start sparking like oh no system
overload glitch what is this too much
coolness
not too much coolness too much unhealthy
behaviors cannot track
data you know what i was thinking about
though like i'm sure back in the day
they were like i wish i could know how
many steps i did in the day and now like
you have all these things that could
track them i feel like in the future
you'll have a wearable that can track
how many calories you ingested yeah i
feel like that's not that crazy not that
far off yeah as opposed to like manually
like you know keeping a journal if
that's something you do with noom right
like it would have yeah i feel like
that's like not that crazy right yeah
that's the future or like for me like
something i would find useful because i
don't care how many calories i consume
my blood alcohol um levels
yeah that would be interesting that's
how far off like a little breathalyzer
ring i would buy it yeah yeah that's
pretty cool or maybe you don't want to
know no sometimes you know what there is
some so much there is a thing as too
much information yeah and i do think
some of my health data is really none of
my own business you know yeah it also
tracks your heart rate so that's how
they like know all this [ __ ] about you
right
i'll keep you guys posted not too often
i don't want to bore everyone to tears
with your aura it's like talking about
your aura statistics like talking about
your dreams
ooh
i think it might i think it's like a
similar no but it's cooler because i can
post about her aura kim has been put
okay but okay what the [ __ ] is she
posting mental health videos yeah no it
makes me think she's like gearing up for
some sort of mental health project the
first one she posted i was like oh she
obviously just saw something that
resonated with her on tic tac and wanted
to share it with her followers like
maybe she was having a bad mental health
day and just like wanted to share the
positivity that's cute that's fine but
now they're coming and it's the same
like style yeah and
i'm just like what the [ __ ] they're so
off-brand yeah that makes me think it's
like really intentional
for some like maybe she's gonna be like
kim's mental health yeah or like you
know how oprah and um
prince harry have that like company like
i think it's gonna be something like
that
yeah i'm seriously like i'm like what
are these like the sentiment is nice but
like seriously like what do you know i
watched the first one in in full just to
see if there was any hidden messages and
now i tap through yeah and like
her timing of them is intentional
because obviously everyone's going to
look at her instagram stories this
weekend and it was nothing it was just
that that yeah and she didn't post on
her feed this weekend because like she's
committed to the flow which i respect
but like
girl we needed i also think post paris
she doesn't post in real time anymore i
know but like we know where she is yeah
yeah no she because she wants like her
blue and pink feet and then i'm sure
she'll switch it and then post all these
looks but come on sometimes you have to
sacrifice the feed really sometimes you
do and that's coming from me like
sometimes
she would have you know broken records
of likes with these moocs yes but also i
just want to say like this whole concept
of like having a beautiful feed is like
kind of outdated people don't really do
that anymore it's different than it was
like and now ever like the feed the
trend of feeds is more like minimal yeah
how do you notice that like some people
just post like wall yeah right but like
also gen z's like attitude towards it is
like whatever post whatever the [ __ ] you
want that's like there's that sect of of
gen z people that are like
i don't know who they follow but where
it's just like chaos and a picture of
sneakers
speakers yeah but even her pictures are
beautiful so like they're not doing that
but then there's also like the new
fashion instagram is like
shoe and palm tree like the next one
will just be like purse on floor and
then like a sickening look
but it's much more minimal where it's
like it used to be like every single
picture in someone's grid was them in a
sickening yes yeah with like the same
filter oh i'm getting a call that i have
to take claudia will you please let us
know who's today's episode is brought to
us by guys i think it's time because
jackie says it's time for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and today's episode oh my god i'm so sad
jackie's not here it's brought to you by
canva pro making content is an essential
part of what we do to keep the show
going but but it hasn't always been a
seamless creative process so before we
join canva pros like very much you know
bootstrapping content neither one of
jackie nor i are like graphic designers
so it was just like not premium and at
the morning toast we believe in premium
content and then we found canva and
canva pro specifically and it has really
upped our social media game if you look
at everything on our instagram the
videos the instagram stories the
graphics all made on canva pro and it
looks like a real graphic designer made
them except you guys know that it's
canva pro a design platform that
empowers you to create and share
stunning content in just a few clicks
designing with canva pro is amazingly
fast and fun you can choose from
thousands of templates that are easy to
customize or you can start from scratch
canva pro has endless premium fonts
photos videos and so much more that add
personality and edge to whatever you're
doing so they have an extensive library
of tools features imagery like whatever
you're trying to make there is a cute
little graphic a cute little element
that you can add that is appropriate for
what you're looking for like you think
oh no canva pro doesn't have this little
gif that i need oh spoiler alert they do
plus you and four teammates can unlock
everything canva pro has to offer just
for 12.99
a month with canva pro's content planner
you'll save time planning editing
creating
and posting social media content you can
pause scheduled posts edit them anytime
so my favorite feature of canva pro is
just like the general um like database
of fonts of shapes of images of little
like um
graphics like things you just never knew
how to make you don't need to learn to
know you you don't need to learn how to
make them because camerapro's got you
covered design like a pro with camphor
pro and right now you can get a free
45-day extended trial when you use our
promo code just go to canva.me
toast to get your free 45-day extended
trial that's c a n v a dot m e slash
toast canva dot me slash toast today's
episode is also brought to you by
caraway home
so if you
love to spend time in your kitchen but
you don't love like scratchy old dirty
pants that like don't have the correct
tops on it check out the caraway
cookware set and the bakeware set so all
of their sets come equipped with easy
access storage solutions so no stacking
is required so gone are the days of
misplacing your lids it's genius and all
of their products are just stunning so
if you like to make content for your
food or you just like like to have a
beautiful kitchen the caraway products
are stunning the cookware set is a
modern and chemical-free iteration of
the traditional 16-piece set but it's
boiled down to the four essentials a
frying pan a saute pan a saucepan and a
dutch oven they also have the bakeware
set which is an assortment of non-toxic
baking essentials that every modern
kitchen needs so you can get to baking
goods without any of the baths here is
why caraway home is great they're
eco-friendly so throughout manufacturing
coward products release up to 60 percent
less co2 into the environment compared
to the traditional non-stick coatings
they're non-toxic so their products are
made without any toxic materials like
pfas ptfe pfoa or any other hard to
pronounce chemicals and it's easy
cooking their naturally slick surface
means minimal oil or butter for slide
off the pan eggs and easy cleaning
so it's time to ditch the chemicals with
caraway homes non-toxic cookware and
bakeware collections so you can make
healthier cooking a piece of cake their
non-toxic kitchenwares are all designed
for the modern home and feature a
chemical-free ceramic coating so food
can be prepared with peace of mind that
no hard-to-pronounce compound will leach
into your healthy ingredients visit
caraway home.com
tmt
to take advantage of this limited time
offer for 10 off your next purchase this
deal is exclusive for our listeners so
visit caraway home that's spelled
c-a-r-a-w-a-y home
tmt or use code tmt at checkout
non-toxic cookware made modern that's
caraway home
um so we have an amazing show for you
guys today i'm very excited it's also
monday so it's unburden yourselves which
if you're unfamiliar with unburden
yourselves is our monday segment where
if you did anything embarrassing over
the weekend and you just kind of want to
get it off your plate start fresh on a
monday write us in on burden yourselves
gmail.com and we will read it today we
have three really unique submissions so
those will be at the end of the show
after the past five which we're going to
do right now great thank you so much
claudia it's a pleasure our first story
really our only story kardashian's ex
dolce
weekend impositano oh and courtney got
married right um but we need to talk
about the whole weekend from start to
finish all of the looks
the synergy
the wedding
let's start from the beginning let's
start from the beginning and just kind
of dissecting this partnership yes like
it was clear that this was very much um
a dolce gama like sponsored event the
you know the day before the wedding they
had a yacht day with everyone that was
the dolce gabbana yacht they had it at
the dolce gabbana castle in italy
everyone's outfits for dolce gabbana so
he just wanted to know like was the
wedding free was this paid like how does
that work i don't know how it works but
based on what i was seeing what i'm
guessing is like
stefano
was like wanting to host the weekend for
courtney and travis i'm sure they
incurred a lot of the costs and they
wanted to address the family what they
received in return was you know you
can't put a price a fashion campaign
that we have not seen
in
years ever yeah especially from dolce
gabbana like it was it's literally like
the best thing to happen to their brand
truly and also they have such a
sickening brand that like you sometimes
forget they have so many iconic
prints and just such a vibe and i was
trying to think of any other brands that
could really do something like this
where it was like every look it just is
oozing with their aesthetics with their
aesthetic like maybe versace yeah you
know but so this was just
beyond amazing yeah and to see the girls
because they're always dressing very
interestingly you know very
runway very futuristic like i'm not
gonna get it for five years but just to
see them and like these gorgeous
feminine looks and then they have like
the glam teams that are able to like
completely match the aesthetic it's like
it was art it was art and it was
literally like i loved the whole vibe
how everyone a lot of people were like
there was no cohesion throughout the
looks and i agree but i do think they
were all on theme and i think the theme
was like roman catholic um
yeah like deep red velvet gold like
elegance so even though like because i
was looking at travis's daughters at the
wedding and they both wore like the same
different dresses but like the same
material and like same vibe and i was
like oh that's so cute it's like very
bridesmaid and like while the kardashian
side didn't have that i did feel like at
least they were all really truly in
theme gothic big oversized crosses lace
there was a cohesion there but you had
to really look like squint no like the
first night i liked some of the
individual looks and together i was like
maybe not but then as the weekend
progressed now when i look at the whole
weekend i'm like oh they're cohesive now
of all the girlies who would you say as
your best dress because mine was quite
shocking actually it's so hard for me
because there really
wasn't a flaw there were some looks that
weren't my favorite but there was not a
flop in the mix and
i think there was one flop actually one
floppy look yeah what would you say i
think it was the first night kim which
is like shocking
the gray outfit yeah oh my god you know
what that was my least favorite look
also first of all it looked like she
like that's something she wears
literally to go to get a salad yeah and
it was not in theme at all she i would
never have known she was in italy yep no
i totally agree that was my least
favorite look it made no sense i
actually felt like she wore it on the
airplane and then like i didn't realize
she sat in glam for that or maybe she
was like resisting falling into dng
because she's very intentional with like
what she does and then maybe she saw
like everyone else looks sickening and
like they had these looks picked out for
her and she's like [ __ ] it i'm gonna go
all in and i'm so glad that she did the
look of her in like the gray corset and
the bootleg pants and the ice cream
stunning sickening okay my i had a lot
of papers i thought chloe looked
incredible too she was my best dress
with kendall a very close second kendall
was stunning but as we say all the time
it's so hard but there was actually one
look the one that she wore on the boat
day where's she set the matching set
where she looked better than the girl
who wore it on the runway years ago
right so like with kendall it's like not
even fair because she's literally a
model and these she was wearing samples
from runway in 1997. like of course
she's literally like she can't stop
that's right that's why i gave chloe my
best dress because chloe's more in my
opinion like one of us you know like
regular girl um and also up there is
miss chris who has been just absolutely
killing it i don't know what has
happened to her in the last couple
months like fashion wise but everything
and we should have known because like
the theme is so crisp it's like opulence
christian catholicism sorry chris yes
like it was so the theme was literally
chris's ideal theme so she killed it
with the big caftans the feathers the
leopard like that's so crisp yeah i
loved kylie's looks too especially being
you know a postpartum mama she looked so
gorgeous the floral dress that she wore
on the boat day with the red lipstick
stunning chef's kiss like it doesn't
from head to toe perfection like her
wedding dress
stunning her wedding wait i'm just
trying to it's like a floral again yeah
same cut gorgeousness the dng black mini
dress with the moto boots and the
matching purse wasn't my favorite not my
favorite the dress itself is an lbd so
cute so fine the boots in the bag were
not my favorite but then the next night
with the jewels
sickening no like thickening so many
looks it was really like they were all
working just over time now by the way
let's talk about the bride we're right
wait no i'm not done okay chloe's thigh
highs and the brown dress on the boat
sickening chloe's leopard corseted like
tight ass that is like d that was the
theme yeah and a dress yeah with the big
oversized cross earrings kim wore the
big cross to the wedding i loved that
yeah a lot of people a lot of the
discourse online was like oh they're
suddenly religious no [ __ ] if you've
been following for a while you know
they're actually deeply spiritual maybe
not like super religious but they pray
all the time they're very like they're
into religion they are interreligion
their favorite word is bible literally
that have to have come from somewhere
yeah yeah yeah because they respect the
bible so if you're going to say bible it
means that it's so true yeah yeah so i
didn't think that like them being like
so
catholic i think um was surprising but a
lot of people were like oh this is
disrespectful to do it for fashion like
no they are
chris jenner is like co-founder of some
church like they are religious people
they are sunday service they go
everywhere oh right yeah so like none of
that was talking to me off the internet
because you see all these crazy takes
and it would never even occur to me and
we can otherwise i think it's important
i think it's important know how [ __ ]
nuts so some people are okay fine like
that that gets backlash a christian
person wearing cross earrings and i'm
sorry i keep going between christian and
catholic i don't know so christian is an
umbrella i know what it is but i don't
know which the kardashians are
they i think they're catholic i think
they're christian but it was very there
were a lot of like catholic elements in
the ceremony because it's italy right
and that's part of the vibe that's my
that's what's my thinking so can we talk
about that that's enough wrong yes we
can let me just make sure like i'm good
on everyone else i just thought it was
like so amazing to see them all dressed
in this way and like such a vibe
it was so
i is anyone else like so [ __ ] excited
by this like you know it was
overwhelming it was overwhelming then
the bride
looks so i really feel like i don't like
to
say negative things about a bride's look
like i really are talking about her
wedding look or the leader all of them
okay because they were all really the
same she wore the same thing to the
wedding the night before she wore it in
black yeah um and then she wore like the
red number the day before um
so i don't i really don't believe in
like critiquing a bride's look i really
don't so what i will say is that
none of them were my cup of tea okay you
do you just not like the length really
well by the way i knew we knew she was
gonna do something different and a lot
of people thought she was gonna wear
like a black dress because she was you
know yesterday was national goth day so
like
of all the she wanted to be edgy and so
to do a mini dress i totally understood
also it's the summer in italy it must
have been hot whatever that particular
dress was not
in my opinion
cute okay
it was undergarments yeah no i liked it
for her and clearly she like loves this
cut recently so she got to like be
herself and feel like herself and in all
the videos and pictures it's just like
another night out with travis and
courtney
i loved her veil and she just like
totally leaned into the aesthetic dng
all of it and um i thought she looked
very happy and and very great yeah so of
all the looks i would say hers were
probably the least impressive to me yeah
um
but i agree the veil was such a moment
and alabama barker that photo that
literally broke the internet from
alabama's instagram story
gorgeous like so and the cool thing was
that it was literally on the side of a
cliff so a lot of the the paparazzi
photos we got we haven't seen any
official wedding photos like just the
paparazzi pictures you see an aerial
view it's literally it was so sick it
was like this
enclave of this cliff like
and from an aerial view it was just all
covered in red velvet red roses and you
could see like the gold accents the
wedding itself i don't know if it was a
mindy weiss um i don't think it was it
was spectacular it was like really dng
yeah literally like the candles the
candelabras it was so
beautiful yeah and it really was only
like 30 people because you could see in
this aerial photo there's like four
benches and there's like eight people on
each it was so different and like so
they're not conventional even though in
a lot of ways their courtship has been
very traditional they're not gonna be
like chugalicious definition like
they're just not gonna be that so it was
very much their own wedding and it was
sick like
the decor it really was and i really
can't think of like a more iconic
glamorous
sin like scene or anything like honestly
it was
giving even more than like kim yay
um the thing is why kimye in my book is
always going to be a little bit of a
higher level was because it was so
private like we'll really never know
what the inside of that wedding looks
like which in my mind makes it so much
it could have been literally in a
basement but we'll never know like the
gl the the mystery makes it so glamorous
that is true but just maybe because we
got so much from this one and everything
we got was just like firing in all
cylinders and how it was so
thematic and the girls were on theme and
also to get the whole family together to
have a family weekend some kids were
there some kids weren't there but also
you get to like see how much they've
grown like north was styling herself yes
and it was just
we like they just gave us so much i just
want to say thank you i do want to say
thank you and i also want to say like i
think the way that courtney and travis's
families have blended is so
nice like you can tell alabama is
obsessed with courtney like she just i
think she's so excited that like her
family she's always been this daughter
of a famous person but not at the level
that it is now and i think she's like
you know she's kind of an influencer so
she's very excited by all of this and
she knows like it's all because of
courtney and her family so i love like
you could tell on the show and then also
at the wedding like everyone was so
happy and i think their blended families
are it's really so nice yeah also the
whole
in all the stories it was like mr and
mrs barker and i just was like thinking
shanna meet the barkers oh it's a dave
show yeah that's so painful imagine if
they were like meet the barkers no i
know and also when they like at the
reception they put on these leather
jackets i said the barker's on the back
yeah i mean that's that's who they are
now speaking of there was conflicting
reports as to whether or not scott was
there he was not there okay because
there were no photos of him but like
there were reports that he was there
there was also reports that beyonce was
there well she was just in italy at the
same hotel that a lot of the guests were
staying at well so was kiara frogne she
was in positano and i was like and fidez
was with one of the drummers um and i
was like is kara going to the wedding
but i don't think she was but she just
chose a funny weekend to be in positano
yeah because there weren't that many
people and i was watching the looking at
the daily mail like people arriving
photos and it was really just like
kardashian inner circle noticeably
absent food god
into a son yeah maybe he's not that
close with courtney yeah the boats that
they all like took up to the cliff like
007 like james bond it was everything it
was really an elegant affair and i just
loved like the calm nature
like the relaxed nature of like the
photos like it wasn't like this big
reveal no photos until vogue gets it
like it was just so i don't know because
it's like they're just so happy they
don't it was just it was so cool it was
so cool and all the girls were like
posting to instagram pretty much in real
time like showing us
the looks the accessories
the food yeah that pasta station food
the pasta another great resource is of
course simon hawk i got a lot of premium
behind-the-scenes content yeah um
gorgeous food and i'm so glad people
were highlighting the food because i
feel like food at those types of affairs
just like
it doesn't get its its moment yeah but
like italy
food
delicious no like some of my favorite
photos and i am looking forward to
getting like actual wedding photos um
the aerial coverage of that wedding from
above like
you never saw something so stunning in
your whole life yeah really premium
decor at that um ceremony you know what
it felt like the way it's supposed to
feel like the met gala yeah just the one
because there was a theme and it's like
okay are you on theme are you not using
them and everyone rolling up seeing how
everyone interpreted the theme like even
when chloe was wearing the headpiece
that she wore to the wedding oh i'm
sorry i totally forgot about the crown
obsessed obsessed so dng
so roman catholic oh my god chloe i'm
telling you she [ __ ] killed it yeah
and a lot of people were like why isn't
true there true was with her dad like
stormy was there so a lot of people were
like well why is true not there if
stormy's not there but none of kids
kim's younger kids came and i feel like
it was just like you know like it's a
tiny wedding chloe wants to get lit and
like uh true has a dad like he can watch
her and i thought it was perfect i'd
love that for chloe no and i like how it
was it wasn't didn't have to be all or
nothing it's like which kids you can
come want to come don't have don't have
prior commitments normalize leaving your
kids at home sometimes honestly no i
normally say taking one kid on a special
trip north just like if it wasn't me i
would be quaking no of course but like
normalized like sometimes you gotta
leave the kids at home sorry like mama's
got a drink on a cliff in portofino and
it is what it is it is what it is i
think the reason why it was so confusing
as to which celebrities were gonna show
up is because it's just like a hot time
in italy right now like yeah it's the
end of may
very expensive place so a lot of
celebrities go there but the celebrities
that were there
mgk and megan
kelly i can't say their names
me
um
1989. um blink 182 members
that's like literally it yeah
that is it yeah
because it was small no and that's like
even more cool you know where was
addison
i'm feeling really sad and weird i'm not
feeling sad or weird i do feel like
first of all a lot of people
a lot of friendships in life just fizzle
i agree so i think people are like what
was there a big break i don't think
there was i think like it was a moment
for courtney but like
courtney kind of
replaced addison with trev yeah
but addison was there for her no i know
and i don't think that they're not
friends anymore i think they're fine but
like not enough to invite her to a
30-person wedding but a year ago she
would have been there she was courtney's
post mom for everything yeah no that's
actually a good point i literally forgot
about that and i just miss them you get
me too and they miss addison with the
family
does courtney still follow addison
i was actually going to check that last
night but then i was like she 100 does
because if she didn't it would be it
would be news people love to like make
up news about people unfollowing other
people on social media yeah i'm just
going to check just like for me she was
the only thing that was missing no
that's a good point i hadn't thought
about that until now
yeah also i think north was there
because she was serving as like premium
contact director yeah
the take talk video she put together and
by the way when she got like artsy at
the end with like the twinkling light
yeah i can
courtney does follow addison okay thank
god oh and kim's
wedding change the crystal oh my god
that crystal body suit was life-changing
and kim was dancing a little bit i know
the paparazzi caught her dancing on the
first night because they were all just
like eating ice cream in like a little
italian village and i guess like the
italian nature just like overcame kim
and she did a little jig yeah which is
very not kim you know she doesn't like
to dance even prince polls are on stage
she wouldn't dance so i'd say she was
like a fine dancer yeah no she's cute
she's such a drama queen about that she
liked the beat
yeah she danced on snl by the way in the
um like mom's in the club sketch oh yeah
i think she's
coming out of her shell it's so funny
that she like doesn't dance no it's the
weirdest thing like what do you do when
you hear a song if you're not going to
dance like
what do you do at a party like i can't
stop my toe from tapping no no like
sometimes a song just oh my god it comes
over it starts
but i think also we just have like a
very musical spirit about us yeah i mean
obviously you know i do because my voice
is amazing so that's not surprising to
anyone yeah and then me as well because
my voice is amazing as well yeah on
opposite day
however is that so all in all grateful
for all the content it was a beautiful
weekend
really at the end of the day like a
gorgeous wedding so happy for the couple
and i'm not gonna lie like i did go on
farfetch and look at dolce gabbana and
what they're selling right now so it was
definitely i was influenced it's a good
um marketing
moment for dj yeah i don't know of a
better one that i've seen recently in
recent history yeah me neither like it's
it's better than like what kim was doing
for balenciaga
like it was beyond so thank you to
everyone i'm sorry to everyone who's
like upset if we were up their ass too
far but this but no that was this was
on another level and this is why like
they are that [ __ ] and i have to be
honest i didn't expect to really care so
much about the wedding weekend yeah no
me neither especially because i just
wasn't expecting to get so much content
but again it was like this free-for-all
even like weddings for like lay people
have rules they ask like you know don't
post a picture of the bride walking down
the aisle until she there's like a
there's like a photo policy at every
wedding no matter to varying degrees so
i just thought this this one was a
free-for-all yeah it was really good and
also who looked really great was travis
yes very traditional you know who looked
incredible rain
rain i knew you were gonna say that the
um wedding ceremony
the little shorts
best dress the cutest thing i've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life in my life in my
life best dress it was amazing it was
like literally
it was glorious that's really all i can
say glorious yeah okay well thank you to
everyone who participated and i would
like to know more about like any
financial transactions between dng and
the family but even if we never find out
that's fine too yeah it was it was
amazing yeah are you ready for our next
story like i guess even though
everything pales in comparison it's
kardashian and jason because snl said
goodbye to kate mckinnon pete davidson
80 brian and kyle mooney on
saturday live this weekend everyone's
really talking about like pete
davidson's departure just because like
was he gonna go to the wedding was he
not he was not there um but kate
mckinnon left as well and people were
very sad about that she left as miss
rafferty yeah the woman who's abducted
by aliens which is one of our favorite
sketches i watched it the episode
it was it was horrible oh it was really
really atrocious and
i think some of like the moments where i
was like uh-huh
we're with 80 kate mckinnon kyle mooney
and pete davidson so
i mean
keenan is literally like the piece of
scotch tape holding this show together
um and i'm sure i mean i don't think he
wants to leave like i think he loves
what he's doing he would do it for the
rest of his life so he must be and i
hope he is being compensated handsomely
for his back breaking work um
it was it was just it was so bad and it
sounds so funny i would never have known
that from all the like highlights
and you know they all got their own
departure um i thought it was really
kate mckinnon's was lovely it was in
like the opening scene and they did that
sketch um which was funny one time
it was funny one time when they did it
with ryan gosling i think that will go
down in history as one of kate
mckinnon's best moments
her and ryan gosling like they can't
breathe it was so funny and then they
just kept trying to recreate the magic
and like is this the alien one yeah i
think it was now the third time they've
done it make it like a recurring thing
um
and i just don't think it was that i
think it was like a really funny moment
once okay i only saw the really funny
moment once i never saw the other ones
so then like the sketch was like well
the aliens need one of you to go live
with them forever and so kate mckinnon
like does this goodbye to earth it's
like a goodbye to snl it was really
sweet um she got a moment
pete davidson got like a whole monologue
on um weekend update edie bryant got
like a nod it was they gave her like
roses but like it wasn't like she didn't
get to say her piece and kyle moon and
none for kyle mooney like literally cal
moony i don't even think it was in the
episode like it was crazy i did skip one
sketch at the end so like maybe it was
in there um
it was just like i thought it was really
interesting like
how pete who let's be honest like has
contributed very little to snl and he
would say he said that in his monologue
he's like you know when i got here
nobody knew what race i was but now they
know i'm a white guy because i literally
got so famous and i'm never here like i
do nothing like he's
really given us nothing on snl he's
given us a lot in pop culture but
nothing on snl um and he got like a
whole monologue like you got to talk to
the camera say thank you to lorne and it
was like so weird it's like 80 brian who
literally is like a queen like she got
like nothing
yeah
that's so interesting why do you think
pete's leaving
i don't know i mean i can't imagine
it'll affect his day-to-day that much
because like i said he was never there
just like holding him back he didn't get
to go to dulchan about an ultimate
wedding yeah so i think moving forward
he's going to be like acting of course
doing stand-up and just like he doesn't
need snl he hasn't needed snl for a
while snl has needed him and snl really
like
every year people leave it's like oh
it's not gonna be the same but like
four
major major like long time cast mates
leaving like that's uh it's a huge blow
yeah and when i think of who's left it's
keenan
it's
chloe feinman
mm-hmm and it's
i don't know why i can only think of his
instagram name faye dunaway but what's
his name
like mikey day no sorry bow and yang i
literally can only think it was
instagram
um
i don't know i don't know where snl goes
from here especially when like it's this
was like aside from kim this was like
really like not a memorable season
yeah i mean none of them really are
sorry where they go from here they keep
going down like it's they just keep
going though nothing is going to stop no
terrible episode is going to stop them
no horrible ratings are going to stop
that how many people watch snl
i think probably like like
i'm just going to guess like 4 million
but i think kim said in her monologue 10
million remember she was like i'm sure
10 million watched her episode yeah
it's just
i don't know it's definitely not gonna
be the same without these people
um
and i now it makes it interesting to see
who they bring on who gets promoted from
like the junior cast to like big big
leagues like yeah
it's
yeah like when kate i think a lot of
people knew when kate mckinnon like the
day eventually came there's been like
rumors about her leaving forever and
there's never been a rumor about keenan
like everyone knows he's staying so i
think when when like the day finally
came that she was going to leave like it
actually would make a rather large
impact yeah i think so too because her
and keenan literally put the show on
their backs for 500 years yeah
so we'll just be interested to see who
gets cast
and what happens next season yeah and
what pete does from here i'm really
sorry only interested in pete and like i
do feel like he left because it was
taking time away from him being in l.a
with him
yeah i actually wouldn't be surprised if
like in a couple years he goes back
really
yeah yeah i don't know if people go back
to snl i don't think so it's a step it's
a step yeah it's a huge one yeah that's
why it's a launching pad but you don't
go back yeah and that's why like i do
feel like people like keenan and kate
mckinnon like have stayed a little too
long unless you want to be an snl or for
life which is super fun i think that's
what keenan wants yeah and like i feel
like if you like living in new york it's
a great job if he has another show on
nbc that's a nice
oh yeah keenan's uh
got cancelled and maybe it's because uh
nbc didn't do like one single commercial
for it but that's a nice life yeah you
know it takes handsomely yeah
you enjoy the job you enjoy the work
maybe you like your co-workers and
sometimes like that's good so yeah
sometimes it's like
don't rock the boat be happy with
contentment because some people make the
jump and then they fall a hundred
percent normalized some people soar
normalize not taking risks and just like
being happy and comfortable in life and
being content i agree
yeah that's a great lesson for today's
episode 100 that's really the lesson of
greatest showman if you watch it with a
keen eye
like sometimes enough is enough and you
don't have to like mortgage your house
to take jenny lindon tour and that's
just a risky bet when you had it all and
sometimes like if you're thinking about
taking another mortgage out on your
house for like a business venture i just
really i would urge you to um just think
about it one more time because it's like
never a good idea when people on shark
tank say like oh i took another mortgage
out on my grandma's house and the sharks
are always like oh my god no business
idea is worth that i'm sorry i know this
entrepreneur hustle culture it's like do
anything you can live on the streets no
actually i have children no and like
grandma needs a place to live right and
don't do it to grandma do it for
yourself yeah but that was the issue
with greatest showman like if he was
just risking on his own
risks
fine but he had a wife and kids and like
they were displaced yeah no that's not
okay and she needs to go to ballet 100
normalized just like you know doing the
bare minimum and being happy yeah
are you ready for our next story
only if it's a story that's brought to
you by
jenny kane home oh thank god
you know jenny kane is a queen you know
this video came up on my tick tock of
someone's like gorgeous gorgeous house
um and like these big siding doors and
all this like gorgeous furniture i saw
the same video it was like outdoor
indoors and i was like whose house is
this and you know whose house it was
jenny kane home and i need jenny kane
home so if you're looking for that
aesthetic which is basically just like
sickening elevated looks
jenny kane home is your ultimate source
for all things home
so they have candles they have throws
they have sofas and it makes your room
just feel so complete so the pacific bed
the miramar sofa the brentwood boucle
chair the harbor sofa they have all
these different pieces that you can add
to your home so the harbor sofa
sectional sofa and sectional comes in
linen it's comfortable it's inviting and
it's minimalist
they are designed to make you instantly
feel feel at home and to make your just
overall like vibe that you're
cultivating at home be elevated check
out their candles and their slippers
which is everything you need at home for
a vibe cultivation session their
california inspired scents are coveted
by all they're hand poured in los
angeles from shearling to suede their
slippers are the ultimate indoor
indulgence jenny came home creates
california inspired classics for any
rumor mood they're grounded in natural
textures and inviting neutrals they are
the pieces you'll love coming home to
you can check out the jenny kane ranch
the latest full-scale interiors project
in santa ines that brings the california
aesthetic to life this remarkable space
was a full gut renovation oh that's what
we saw on tick tock follow jenny kane
and jenny kane home on instagram to
check it out and you can get 20 off all
their furniture and home decor plus
early product access and much more with
a jkh membership join at
jennykaine.commembership
or go to jennycane.com home to create
the space you'll never want to leave
so to learn more about that membership
it's jennycaine.commembership
and to check out all of this
paces to cr pieces to create the space
you'll never want to leave it's
jennykaine.com
home j-e-n-n-i-k-a-y-n-e
dot com slash home gorgeous gorgeous
things i have a blanket from jenny kane
home that has just totally elevated my
space the slippers the candles it's
everything
our next story some relationship news
becca tilly and hailey kyoko have
confirmed their relationship and they
are now instagram official becca tilly
and her girlfriend haley kiyoko went
instagram official with a sweet video
montage on friday becca posted it and
said hard to say if this is a hard or
soft launch but it is a launch the video
i have watched it so many times it's
like a look at their relationship
they've been together for four years now
so there is just so much content really
sweet content also they both have like
very fascinating high lives like haley
kyoko on stage with taylor swift like
and so it's all these really big moments
that they've shared over the last four
years there's not a dull moment in the
video
and it is so beautiful to watch i'm so
excited that they've come out with their
relationship and i mean four years is a
long time to be with someone so this is
the real deal yeah and so i don't know
if it was necessarily it wasn't like a
secret i think a lot of
becca definitely kept it private but
becca has a podcast and she talks about
her partner on the podcast and she
avoided pronouns but a lot of people
knew who it was and she wasn't like
hiding from it i just think this is her
first obviously like gay relationship
and it took her like a long time to get
to a place where she was comfortable
sharing it publicly and what i think is
so cool is like how patient haley kyoko
was like because haley kyoko's out she's
been out for a while she's kind of like
a queer icon um and so i think a lot of
people in that place in their life like
wouldn't want to be with someone who
isn't there yet because it's like
traumatic to relive it and a lot of
people just don't want to be in
relationships with people who are quote
unquote like closeted but i think like
the way that like haley was so patient
like four years is a long time patient
with becca they had like this full-blown
relationship that most people didn't
know about and now that it's out and it
was in promo with one of haley's songs
which is like such a good song i just i
loved everything about this yeah and so
the music video for the song the song's
called for the girls and the music
videos like this whole like bachelor
mansion night one sort of uh
reenactment so it's all very full circle
yeah and becca's like the last girl to
get out of the limo it was so cute the
so it's great promo for the song and
also just must be nice to have their
relationship out there
and it seems like they've been having a
great time over the last four years and
it's also nice to like enjoy
something like so private privately
agreed you know agreed
also i mean they always say that like
when people start to date like they look
alike but for me am i the only one who
thinks like becca and haley are like
twins
i think they like
i don't think they're twins they look so
alike to me but i i i see that with all
couples like whenever i'm like get to
know a couple and like no you and ben
are brother and sister right now
everyone you guys always say that me and
zach look like olivia and shapiro are
like literally twins so and even like
with my friendships like i always feel
like once a couple's like really meant
to be together i start seeing them as
like literal twins yeah that's how i
feel with becca and haley yeah
totally i'm so happy for becca like this
is this is awesome this is awesome
congrats congrats
some more congrats and in oops ellen
degeneres seemingly revealed the sex of
jennifer lawrence three-month-old baby
oh my god of course ellen literally
making everything about herself ellen
appeared to reveal the sex of jennifer
lawrence's three-month-old when the
actress made her final appearance on the
ellen degeneres show ellen said people
don't know this but i used to live in
the house that you live in now when i
started the show 20 years ago she said
to jennifer over the phone on monday's
episode now i live next door to you and
i'm looking at you living in my house
with a brand new baby by the way i do
hear you sometimes talking to him the
finding dory star noted that lawrence's
conversations with her apparent baby boy
are really cute
so in ellen's defense like to know the
um gender of someone's baby and then
like talk about the baby without using
pronouns is really hard and to remember
like who shared what information so we
know that you're pregnant we know that
you had your baby but you didn't tell us
the gender of the baby it's a lot to
keep apart so i don't believe there was
male intent from ellen for the first
time in her
career history um but like don't you uh
edit your own show like cut it out yeah
also this idea like we've seen aerial
shots of ellen's homes like you can hear
your neighbors like she's trying to be
like the rest of us like yeah i can hear
my upstairs every time they drop a
[ __ ] fork on the floor 100
no the person who lives above my bedroom
like absolutely has to get a carpet they
must have a child who drops a ping pong
ball 45 times a day and i hear it and
it's so it's just like a weird sound
it's like
oh that's it's so random and i'm like
[ __ ] get a carpet it makes you wonder
what your downstairs neighbors hear
about you because like i don't really
have many carpets in my house i have
carpets i have three carpets and i'm
always moving and grooving no i hear
upstairs like when they pull out the
dining room chairs but the thing is like
they're doing it at really [ __ ] weird
times of the day but maybe they work
from there or maybe like it's not dining
room chair being pulled out and i'm just
like hearing something else yes maybe
it's not a ping pong ball that i'm here
no but sometimes like they drop
something you can hear it roll yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i doubt that's
happening to ellen agreed but like i
drop stuff all the time and i don't have
a lot of rugs like i just wonder what
the people beneath me are hearing i know
it can't be that bad or else maybe they
would have said something no but you
don't say anything you just live with it
because that's just life um also new
york city speaking of so we know you
can't [ __ ] hear jennifer talk to her
baby when you're acres away 100 but
speaking of ellen like living in
jennifer living in ellen's house one of
my favorite things about like celebrity
culture is like there are really only so
many like mega mansions in like the the
areas that celebrities live in that so
many celebrities like live in each
other's houses like to read living in
jayla's old house for like temporarily
chloe and lamar living in jessica
simpson and nicolas shea's old house
like i love that and i just saw oh uh
cara delevingne bought a 15 million
tribeca penthouse from jimmy fallon yeah
like i just that's like my favorite
thing in celebrity culture like house
swap yeah that is interesting yeah
because there are only so many people
who can afford a 15 million dollar
penthouse and like most of them are
probably famous yeah
must be nice must be nice anyways these
are new neighbors and jennifer lawrence
had a boy oh that's cute in february
jennifer lawrence february 2022 was like
a really pop a month to give birth yeah
it's you it's kylie it's jayla who else
morgan stewart oh do you see morgan
stewart's birthday of course
you know she's just like setting an
impossible standard but we love to see
it no not only that like
it's just like it's just not fair like
you know like i was born this
and morgan stewart was born that
and
i don't know i just i i object i really
do i know but at least like i just love
watching people live like such
wonderfully fabulous lives
at least like she's sharing with you and
like having like to be someone who
actually like knows more concern on a
personal level like she couldn't be
nicer you know like it's just like you
want to hate her so much and like we
need to find a reason because currently
i have none no i love i like i just love
i love her
yeah i love the fabulousness and i'm so
happy for her and like not at all
jealous yeah no and like she had this
two this huge party she had two babies
in two years like she deserves a big ass
party yeah yeah i think that's what she
was thinking too yeah
now are you ready for our fifth and
final story
[Music]
no she's not
now she is
it's the final story
[Music]
[Music]
and that's a magic
number
our fifth and final story jojo cat has
canceled her festival appearances and
dropped out of tour due to tonsil
surgery doji had announced friday that
she's going under the knife for routine
tonsil surgery affecting several
upcoming performances she said hey guys
i wanted you to hear from me first
unfortunately i have to have surgery on
my tonsils asap the surgery is routine
but the recovery is going to take a
while due to the swelling that means i
have to cancel my festival around this
summer as well as the weekend tour i
feel horrible about this but i can't
wait to heal and get back to making
music and create an experience for y'all
so um she's been really open about this
you know why she
she has an abscess on her tonsil from
vaping yeah no and like she was having
some issues and instead of like you know
listening to her body and resting she
was drinking vaping and at the bbmas
right and so um
this is you know a huge loss for every
person who was planning on going to a
concert this summer because if i've
learned anything from being on the
concert side of tick tock it's that
literally nobody who performs quite like
to cat wow she she is that [ __ ] like
she's dancing she's dancing at 100 she's
singing in 100 she's giving it all at
100 she's someone who like i didn't
really know until i was like watching
award shows and i was like oh wow this
girl's got it going on and she's that
girl who was like okay have i ever sat
down on spotify and pressed play doja
cat no do i know every song no every
song it's because her songs are so
ingrained in pop culture especially on
tic-tac-toe yeah woman
like she is literally
the soundtrack of last year no literally
i've never played doji cat on spotify i
know all the hits it's crazy and i don't
even like listen to the radio no it's
really from tick tock yeah and real you
kiss me mom and also instagram stories
like and also
the one like get into it yeah get into
it yeah
that one yeah why don't you say like i
did uh because i don't think that was
right but i wasn't gonna call you out i
just wanna
get into it yeah yep thank you that's
better that's not what you said the
first time
no she says it differently like in
different parts of the song
you obviously just well no the clip that
people use for their instagram stories
is short and that's all you know exactly
yeah exactly um wishing doja the best
wishing dojo the best a speedy recovery
refused to do
and
we have three girlies who wrote in today
who might also need some well wishes so
if you could welcome me if you could
join me in welcoming the unburdened
segment that would be great welcome to
the unburden yourself segment where you
guys tell us the cringe things you did
this weekend and we help you release
those burdens into the ether i've read
criticisms that were too judgy on
unburdening yourselves but that's part
of the unburdening process you have to
acknowledge how bad it is we need to
process it we can't just let it go no
and what we should be ignorant like and
make you think like what you did was
nothing no no we have to be we have to
acknowledge how cringy what you did is
in order for us to truly be able to let
it go and if you keep reading podcast
reviews i'm quitting i think it was like
a youtube comment and we need to process
it's part of the process you obviously
don't know you don't host the segment
you don't know speaking you don't know
how to unburden it speaking of youtube
comments subscribe alright unburden
yourselves is brought to you by favor
which is previously the pill club a
digital health company that sees you
whole from birth control and sexual
wellness to include to skin care and
menstrual care and it's all backed by
medical expertise so that includes
discrete delivery for self-care goodies
and the number of brands that they offer
is quite wide so it's no secret that
women face a lot of choices about their
reproductive health but luckily getting
birth control in sexual wellness
products is one less thing you have to
worry about with favor you'll never have
to make the trip to the doctor or wait
in line at the pharmacy ever again favor
provides personalized access to care
from the comfort of your own home and
delivery to your door in discrete
packaging the pill club now favor offers
professionally prescribed birth control
subscriptions and sexual wellness
products delivered straight to your door
they carry over 120 fda approved brands
at favor and they ship to all 50 states
most brands of birth control are free
with insurance or medicaid otherwise
prices start as low as seven dollars a
month they deliver birth control to your
door for free and discreet packaging
along with fun self-care gifts and
goodies right now when you go to
hayfavor.com toast favor is offering a
10 donation to bedsider.org for every
morning toast listener who becomes a
patient
your donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org that's hey
favor.com toast to get your first birth
control care package and donate to help
more women in need of affordable birth
control remember that's hey favor.com
toast you have to use that link if you
want to make the donation all right
ready
dear claudia and jackie first of all
love you guys love the toast it's an
integral part of my day so on thursday
night i went out with my friends for a
little pre-graduation festivities and
while i was getting ready i discovered a
mole on my back that i've never felt
before
being the hypochondriac that i am i made
a reminder in my phone to remind me
friday at 9 00 am to call my
dermatologist and make an appointment
good for you i labeled the reminder tell
dr potter about my mole
fast forward to friday morning
there's a boy in my bed that i've been
casually hooking up with this semester
let's call him jimmy jimmy and i are
scoring through tick tocks on my phone
when the lovely reminder saying tell dr
potter about my mole pops open on my
screen i immediately lock my screen and
the room is completely silent we didn't
talk about what he just read on my phone
but it was certainly the elephant in the
room i know it's not a big deal and if
anything we love a health conscious
girly we do but now when i think of
jimmy i can't help but think that he
perceives me as the girl
as a girl with a big fat male water back
anyway i probably won't see him again
since we're all moving away after we
graduate but i thought i should share
this unfortunate story and unburden
myself love you guys sincerely an
embarrassado toaster i understand the
embarrass ottoman but when you zoom out
of the situation like you're just being
conscious about your health like that's
so proactive in you and you know girls
who are pro who are conscious of their
health and proactive of their health you
know what they make great wives right so
i think the pride in this situation
should outweigh any shame sure
inopportune time for jimmy who you just
met to see this on your phone but you
know what like you're doing something
right in general but you know what's
funny what makes this funny is like if
she had had a notification that was like
remind reminder to tell dr potter about
rash it would have been like
way like there's something rush isn't
great but there's something about a mole
that is inherently embarrassing and i
don't know if it's like because it looks
like duty like i don't know what it is
about the mold that people like i i have
had moles i've actually had three moles
removed like they were the bane of my
existence i used to photoshop them out
in photos there is something deeply
shameful about moles and i think that's
what makes this situation probably the
worst medical thing she could have had
like a rash it could be contagious like
that would be worse no it could be you
have a rash because you're dirty like
rashes should be more embarrassing no
and i think it's also the word mole
that makes it like even more gross like
if you had said beauty mark would have
been different freckle beauty spot like
i don't know but there's something about
the word and the look of a mole
that i don't know why it must be some
like deep psychological thing but
there's something horrifying about it
yes but we need to
destigmatize a hundred percent you know
and i think this is a really great start
and you are taking care of your body of
your health and i think you should only
feel pride but i am and we should all be
checking our moles all the time this is
a great message for everyone
sorry checking our beauty marks
freckles freckles yeah like and you know
what of all the people that could have
happened in front of at least it was
happening like some guy you were [ __ ]
in college who like you're obviously not
in love with right now it's graduation
weekend right like shout out to dr
potter yeah you know what dr potter
sounds like a nice guy is he single
wow you just assumed he was oh
i did
misogyny literally and you know what my
favorite literally my absolute favorite
party trick is this riddle please i know
it okay i'm gonna say the riddle do you
know this riddle okay i'm gonna tell you
the riddle and you tell me if you have
an answer okay
a man and his son are driving in the car
and they get into a terrible accident
terrible accident
the father dies immediately and the boy
is taken in an ambulance to the hospital
putting him on the table for surgery the
doctor comes in he looks over at this
patient this boy and he says this boy is
my son
how is that possible
okay so she did and by the way you said
that he looks over the doctor comes in
and he looks over oh yeah you have to be
okay also i think i spoiled it and of
course you spoiled it yeah because we
were talking about
yeah
i know i didn't want to interrupt you
because you were like no as i was saying
the riddle i was thinking i'm like well
she's going to know because i literally
just said but i just want to say in my
like intro to media class somebody the
teacher said that in the first day and
like all these like you know
it was all like women in my class and
they're like you know hardcore like real
feminist not one everyone's listening
the dad came back to life no it's a
ghost no no people are like oh oh he has
two dads
and it's like no keep guessing the
spirit of the dad came back people
always say that or people are like oh
the dad didn't die yeah right just the
cadaver of the dad like
so okay i guess i've ruined the poem
that is my favorite part you tried to do
something yeah and that's important too
and you know what this girl you have
literally nearly not one thing to worry
about no but please let us know if dr
potter is a man or a woman yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah
hi jackson claude this incident has been
haunting me and i finally decided maybe
unburden yourselves as my way out i have
a girlfriend that is a consistent
one-upper any story i tell her a place i
travel she's been there she's done
something better a few weeks ago she was
in vegas and texted me that she
discovered this amazing and adorable
restaurant that would be so cute for her
wedding brunch it was siddell's
so i replied oh yeah it's cute i've been
i've been to their new york location a
couple times and i totally dismissed her
i've actually never been to sedel's when
i've been in new york or vegas but i
know that there is one there and i just
felt like making her feel like her
discovery was a big nothing burger
totally i'm not usually so petty or a
liar but i hope this helps me relieve
some of my guilt i love this for you
love love is lying to make other people
feel bad to make other people feel small
especially
especially if their intention was to
make you feel small no you shouldn't go
around like making other people feel
small but if this is the person who's
constantly making others feel small
normalize pulling something out of your
ass and also like sometimes you make
other people feel small like
accidentally and like i'm sorry that's
not on me like that's on you yeah but if
you're intentionally trying to make
people feel small it is your civic duty
to try and make that person feel small
also citizens arrest
also discovering cidels like
girl no and if you like if you're one
upper you have to be like really
extremely cosmopolitan well-trained
right and a true one-upper would know
that like the vegas siddells is like the
big blown out kind of commercial version
and like the really niche small like
west village one is the one you want to
go into the original and i'm no but
sedels is also opening there's one in
miami dallas there's one in dallas now
so they are popping up and maybe if you
were like you know in dallas and you
just heard of this new restaurant
opening you'd be like oh i discovered it
but then you have to come in and let
this girl know like you've been in new
york and i really love it for you me too
and you know what i'm i think this
girl's like one upper facade is about to
deteriorate because a true one-upper
would know that like if a restaurant is
in vegas it's certainly not the first
location it's a restaurant franchise
that got so big that they were able to
open in vegas so she's not even really
cultured where did vegas come into the
situation here the girl was in vegas and
found siddells discovered in vegas and
was like i found this great restaurant
for my wedding brunch or whatever got it
okay yeah no
it's okay as long as like the person is
nefarious it's okay if you you know if
you're nefarious back sometimes and this
is like season one luanne de la sept
sometimes the only way to deal with one
upper is to one-up them yeah no it's
even to the point of like comical like
that's what they did to luanne luanne
used to always season like one and two
be like oh i was in the south of france
oh i went to the south of france once in
1997 like
and sometimes the best way to deal with
that is like they don't even realize
they're doing it so you have to be so
obvious like well i went to 1985. like
you have to really like comically almost
satire that's the only way people can
see themselves yeah and sometimes they
still can't but it's fun
it's fun to play yeah all right third
and final hello jackie and claudia so
happy to have you both together again
and jackie congrats on the bed thank you
so much the most humiliating thing known
to mankind happened to me and if i don't
unburden myself i might just pass away
i'm trying to get a tan and look
somewhat snatched for summer so i head
over to my tannic salon i jump into bed
and i'm laying there for about five
minutes before my body decides that it's
now or never i'm about to poop
i jump out of the bed begin trying to
put my clothes on to run to the bathroom
but ultimately it's too late i squat
over the small trash can in the corner
of the room and quite literally take the
largest stump i've ever seen
now i'm in a full panic because i've
just [ __ ] in the trash can and there
there's no way to dispose of it so i
take the mini trash can throw it in my
purse and leave
sorry wait i lost my and leave as fast
as i can now i think i'm in the clear
until later that day my phone starts to
ring and it's the tanning salon hello
miss it seems one of our trash cans is
missing and we looked at the cameras and
it happened right after you were here in
this moment i metaphorically [ __ ] myself
again so to say the least they know it
was me and i can never show my face in
this establishment ever again you know
what i think is more shameful than
taking a dump in a garbage can it's
going to a tanning bed girl like it's 20
22. those uv rays are cancerous what is
wrong with you seriously get your moles
checked right here we are in one breath
talking about the importance of getting
your moles checked and there's a girl
willingly going into a tanning bed yeah
girl get a spray tan okay i'm really
shocked by like
barring
other circumstances like the no no virus
maybe a laxative hit you at the wrong
time like is this something that happens
where you just like have to [ __ ] and you
can't even make it to the toilet you
know
it could be a combination of like
chipotle for lunch like you don't know
what she ate it's not it's not super
common but like everyone has moments
like that like where it just randomly
hits you out of nowhere okay i mean so
you shot at least it was in the trash
not on the floor yeah why didn't you
take the trash bag also
they called you because the trash can
was missing like that's a little petty
no that's like a low budget tannic salon
and that's where you're gonna go get
into a chemical bed
and they're like
by the way they have cameras in the
rooms when you're naked yeah i thought
that was weird too
something's not adding up mm-hmm
um but i think the real shame here is
that you go to tanning salons and i
think that you shouldn't do that anymore
it's like it's literally the dumbest
thing you could do yeah no it's not good
there's so many better alternatives
i know it's like a little less natural
looking but your skin will thank you
yeah and so i'm glad you wrote in i know
that probably wasn't the advice that you
were looking for um
but it's the one you got and it's it's
more important yeah and i'm just
confused about the whole situation too
also if you guys did something
embarrassing over the weekend and you
want to write in it's unburden
yourselves
gmail.com unburden yourselves at
gmail.com that will never get easier to
say like i know i'm glad like we have
this segment but the name like sucks
um well that was our show
you want to change the name out you said
the name sucks you know i don't want to
change your name because i'd like that
it was like naturally stemmed from
something that happened here on the show
like you literally took a burden from me
and like it's all very natural how it
happened or we could call it like the
unburdening
but then we'd have to change the email
oh and then you would have to like say
that under a new one just leave it leave
it like okay okay we'll leave it unless
you can't take it anymore or you know i
could do the segment i would absolutely
love that i'll do this segment because
you're always like coming in from an ad
you're reading a lot but the it's nice
when you have to read two because then i
can make fun of you when you like
stumble
yeah when you stumble and you step up
even though i don't you they don't
oh wow oh wow
really really
are you okay are you okay
thank you so much thank you so much for
listening to the morning the millennial
morning show where we deliver the
stories that you
please don't forget to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available seriously subscribe we're also
available as podcasting podcasts we
found so spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i heart radio cast box all the
places so whatever you listen to podcast
find us the morning toast and leave a
five-star review okay about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
how i don't act differently when i speak
to 21 year olds okay leave a review have
an amazing monday we'll see you tomorrow
for our very special episode with our
very special guest yes we will goodbye
is
you